so we spend the last few lectures
discussing similarities regularity lemma
so we saw that this is an important tool
with important applications allowing you
to do things like a proof of roster via
graph theory one of the concepts that
came up when we were discussing this
statement of summary destroy clarity
lemma it's that of pseudo randomness so
the statement of some Redis graph
regularity lemma is that you can
partition an arbitrary graph into a
bounded number of pieces so that the
graph looks random like as we call it
between most pairs of parts okay so what
does random like me so that's something
that I want to discuss the next couple
of lectures and this is the idea of
pseudo randomness which is a it's a
concept that it's really prevalent in
combinatorics in the radical computer
science and in many different areas and
what pseudo randomness tries to capture
is in what ways can a non random object
look random
alright so before diving into some
specific mathematics I want to offer
some philosophical remarks and so you
might know that you know income on a
computer you want to generate a random
number while you type in a Rand and it
gives you a random number but of course
you know that it's not necessarily true
randomness it came from some
pseudo-random generator
probably there's some seed and some
complex looking function and output
something that you couldn't distinguish
from random but it might not actually be
random it's just something that looks in
many different ways like random so there
is this concept of randomness you can
think about a random graph right
generate this address writing a random
graph every edge occurs independently
with some probability but I can also
show you some graph some specific graph
which I say well it's
just for all intents and purposes just
as good as a random graph so in what
ways can we capture that concept so
that's what I want to discuss and that's
the topic of pseudo randomness and of
course well you know this idea extends
to in the many areas number theory and
whatnot but we'll stick with graph
theory in particular I want to explore
today just one specific notion of pseudo
randomness and this is comes from an
important paper called quasi random
graphs and this concept is due to Chung
Graham and Wilson back in the late 80s
so they defined various notions of
pseudo randomness and I want to state
them and what it turns out and the
surprising part is that these notions
these definitions although they look
superficially different they're actually
only equivalent to each other so let's
see what the theorem says so the set up
of this theorem is that you have some
fixed real P between 0 & 1
and this is going to be your graph edge
density so for any sequence of graphs GN
so with so from now I'm going to drop
the subscript G so subscript n so G will
just be G n such that the number of
vertices so to genius and vertex with
extensity basically peep okay so this is
your sequence of graphs and the claim is
that we're going to state some set of
properties and these properties are all
going to be equivalent to each other
[Applause]
okay so all of these properties capture
some notion of pseudo randomness in what
ways does this graph G or really a
sequence of graphs or you can talk about
a specific graph and have some error
parameters and error balance they're all
roughly the same ideas so in what ways
can we talk about this graph G being
random like well we already saw one
notion when we discussed similarities
regularity lemma and let's see that here
so this notion is known as discrepancy
and it says that if I restrict my graph
to looking only at edges between some
pair of vertex sets then the number of
edges should be roughly what you expect
based on density along so this is
basically the notion that came up in
epsilon regularity this is essentially
the same as saying that G is epsilon
regular with itself for this epsilon now
hidden in this little old parameter so
that's one notion of pseudo randomness
okay so here's another notion which is
very similar so it's almost just a
semantic difference okay so I have to do
a little bit of work so let me call this
this prime so it says that if you look
at only edges within a set so instead of
taking two sets I only look at one set
and then look at how many edges are in
there versus how many you should expect
based on density alone
these two numbers are also very similar
to each other so let's get to something
that looks dramatically different the
next one I'm going to call count so
count says that for every graph H the
number of labeled copies of H in G okay
so labeled copies I mean that the
vertices of H are labeled so for every
triangle there are six labeled triangles
that correspond to that triangle in the
graph the number of labeled copies of H
is okay so what should you expect if
this graph will truly random you expect
P raised to the number of edges of h
plus small error times n number raised
to the number of vertices of H and just
as a remark this little old term one
term may depend on H so this condition
count says for every graph H this is
true and by that I mean for every H
there's some sequence of decaying errors
but that sequence of the K nares may
depend on your graph H
the next one is almost a special case of
count
it's called c4 and it says that the
number of labelled copies of c-4 to the
four cycle yes at most P raised to power
4 ok so again what you should expect in
a random setting just for cycle count
alone I see already some of you are
surprised and we'll discuss that you
know this is an important constraint it
turns out that alone implies everything
just having the correct c4 count the
next one we'll call Co degree and the co
degree condition says that if you look
at a pair of vertices and look at their
number of common neighbors in other
words their Co degree then what should
you expect this quantity to be and
vertices that possibly could be common
neighbors and each one of them if this
were a random graph with edge
probability P then you expect the number
of common neighbors to be around pqube a
p squared n so the co degree condition
is that this sum is small so most pairs
of vertices have roughly the correct
number of common neighbors degree yes
number of common neighbors
next in the last one certainly not the
least is I can value condition so here
we are going to denote by lambda 1
through lambda G the eigenvalues of the
adjacency matrix of G okay so we saw
this object in the last lecture I
include multiplicities if some
eigenvalue occurs with multiple times
that included multiple times so the
eigenvalue condition says that the top
eigenvalue is around pn and that more
importantly the other eigenvalues are
all quite small now for D regular graph
the top I can value it's fine to think
about D regular graphs you know if you
want to get some intuition out of this
term for D regular graph the top I can
value is equal to D because the top
eigenvector is there's the old one
vector so top eigenvector is a one
vector which has eigen value T and what
I can value condition says is that all
the other eigen values are
much smaller right so here I'm thinking
of des on the same order of SN okay so
this is the theorem so that's what we'll
do today well prove that all of these
properties are equivalent to each other
and all of these properties you should
think of as characterizations of pseudo
randomness and of course this theorem
guarantees us that it doesn't matter
which one you use their own equivalent
to each other and you know our proofs
are actually going to be I mean I'm
going to try to do everything fairly
slowly but none of these proofs are
difficult we're not going to use any
fancy tools like some radix regularity
lemma and in particular all of these
quantitative errors are reasonably
dependent on each other so I've stated
this theorem so far in this form where
there's a little one error but
equivalent ly so can equivalently state
them State theorem for example disk with
an epsilon error which is that some
inequality is true with a most epsilon
error instead of oh and you have a
different epsilon for each one of them
and the theorem turns out that okay so
the proof of this theorem will be that
these conditions are true so all
equivalent up to at most a polynomial
change in the epsilon in other words so
property one is true for epsilon implies
that property two is true for some
epsilon raised to a constant so the
changes in parameters are quite
reasonable and we'll see this from the
proof but I won't say it again
explicitly any
questions so far about the statement of
this theorem so as I mentioned just now
the most surprising part of this theorem
and the one that I want you to pay the
most attention to is the c4 condition
this seems at least at face value the
weakest condition among all of them it
just says the correct c4 count but it
turns out to be equivalent to everything
else and there's something special about
c-4 right if I replace c-4 by c3 by just
triangles then that's not true so I want
you to think about you know where the
c-4 played this important role how does
it play this important role okay so
let's get started with the proof but
before that let me so in this proof one
recurring theme is that we're going to
be using the Cauchy Schwarz inequality
many times and I want to just begin with
an exercise that gets you some
familiarity with applying the Cauchy
Schwarz inequality and this simple tool
but it's extremely powerful and
worthwhile to you know master how to use
the Cauchy Schwarz inequality okay so
let's let's get some practice let me
prove a claim which is not directly
related to the proof of the theorem but
it's indirectly in that explains
somewhat the c-4 condition why we have
less than or equal to over there okay so
the lemma is that if you have a graph on
n vertices such that the number of edges
is at least P and squared over 2 so edge
density basically P then the number of
labeled copies of c-4 is at least
e to the 4 - little one and so if you
have a graph with edge density P P is a
constant then the number of C forces are
at least roughly what you would expect
in a random graph alright so let's see
how to do this and I want to show this
inequality as a me I'll show you how to
prove this inequality but I also want to
draw sequence of pictures that at least
to explain how I think about
applications of the Cauchy Schwarz
inequality ok so the first thing is that
we are counting labelled copies of c4
and this is basically but not exactly
the same as number of homomorphic copies
of c-4 in g so by this guy here i really
just mean you are mapping vertices of
c-4 to g so that the edges all map to
edges but we are allowing not
necessarily injective maps c4 to 2g but
that's okay so the number of non
injective maps yes most cubic so we're
not really affecting our account so it's
enough to think about homomorphic copies
okay so what's going on here
so let me draw a sequence of pictures
illustrating this calculation so first
we are thinking about counting c4 c4 I
can rewrite the c-4 count as a sum over
pairs of vertices of G as the squared Co
degree and what happens here so this is
true mean it's not hard to see why this
is true but I want to draw this in
pictures because you know we have larger
and bigger graphs may be more difficult
to think about the algebra unless you
have some visualization so what happens
here is that I noticed that this c4 has
a certain reflection namely it has a
reflection along this horizontal line
and so if I put these two vertices as U
and D then this reflection tells you
that you can write this homomorphic
number who more copies as the sum of
squares but once you have this
reflection and reflections are super
useful because they allow us to get
something into a square and then right
after apply the Cauchy Schwarz
inequality so we apply Cauchy Schwarz
here and we obtain that this sum is at
most where I can pull the square out and
I need to think about what is the
correct factor to put out here and that
should be okay so what's the correct
factor that I should put out there okay
so 1 over N squared so I don't actually
like doing this kind of calculations
which sums because then you have to keep
keep track of these normalizing factors
one of the upcoming chapters when we
discuss graph limits or in fact you can
even do this instead of taking sums if
you take an average if you take an
expectation then it turns out you never
have to worry about these normalizing
factors and so on somehow normalizing
factor should never bother you if you do
it correctly but just to make sure
things are correct
this keep me in check all right so what
happened in this step in this step we
pulled out that square and pictorially
what happens is that we got rid of half
of this picture so we used
cauchy-schwarz and we wiped out half of
the picture and now what we can do is
while we're counting these guys these
paths of length two but I can
reprioritize this picture so that it
looks like that and now I notice that
there is one more reflection all right
so there's one more reflection and
that's the reflection around the
vertical axis so let me call this top
vertex X and I can rewrite the sum okay
so once more with your cauchy-schwarz
which allows us to get rid of half of
the picture and now I'm going to draw
the picture first Stan you see that what
we should be left with it's just a
single edge and then you write down the
correct sum making sure that all the
parentheses and normalizations are
correct but somehow that doesn't worry
me so much because I know this what that
means the
but whatever it is were just summing the
number of edges so that's just a number
of edges and okay so we put everything
in and we find that the final quantity
is at least P raised to 4 and 2 4 ok so
I did this quite slowly but and also
emphasizing the sequence of pictures
on and party to tell you like how I
think about these inequalities because
for other similar looking inequalities
in fact there is something called
sidorenko's conjecture which I may
discuss more in a future lecture that
says that this kind of inequality should
be true whenever you replace c4 by any
bipartite graph and that's a major open
problem in combinatorics it's kind of
hard to keep track of these calculations
unless you have a visual anchor and this
is my visual anchor which I'm trying to
explain
of course it's down-to-earth it's just
the sequence of inequalities and this is
also some practice with cauchy-schwarz
alright any questions so but one thing
in this calculation told us is that if
you have edge density P then you
necessarily have c4 density at least P
to the fourth so that party explains why
you have at most n here so you always
know that it is at least this quantity
so the c-4 quasi randomness condition
it's really the equivalent to replacing
this less than or equal to u by an equal
sign ok so let's get started with
proving the chunk um Wilson theorem so
the first place that we'll look at is
the two versions of disk disk stands for
discrepancy okay so first fact that disk
implies this prime I mean this is pretty
easy you take Y 2 equal to X be slightly
careful about the definitions but you're
okay not much to do that
the other direction
where you only have discrepancies for
single sets and you want to produce
discrepancies four pairs of sets ok so
this is actually a fairly common
technique in algebra that allows you to
go from bilinear forms to quadratic
forms and vice versa it's that kind of
calculation so let me do it here
concretely in this setting so here what
you should think of is that you have two
sets x and y and they might overlap and
what they correspond to in the and you
think about the corresponding Venn
diagram where I am looking at ways that
a vertex and fall in pair of vertices
can fall in X and/or Y so if you have x
and y and so it's useful to keep track
of which vertices are in which set but
what the thing finally comes down to is
that the number of edges with one vertex
in X on one vertex in Y I can write this
bilinear form type quantity as a course
as an appropriate some just number of
edges in single sets okay so there are
several ways to check that this is true
one way is to just tally and keep track
of how many edges are you counting in
each step so if you are trying to count
the number of edges in yeah so let's say
if you're trying to count the number of
edges in with one vertex in x one vertex
in Y then what this corresponds to is
that count but let me do a reflection
and then you see that you can write this
some say alternating sum of principal
squares so this one big square plus the
middle square and minus the 2 side
squares which is what that sum comes to
alright so if we assume this prime then
I know that all of these individual sets
have roughly the correct number of edges
up to a little o of n squared error and
again like I don't have to do this
calculation again because it's the same
calculation so the final thing should be
P times the sizes of x and y together
Plus this same error ok so that shows
you this prime implies disk so the self
version of discrepancy implies the pair
version and discrepancy so let's move on
to count
to show that disk implies count actually
we already did this so this is the
counting lemma so the counting lemma
tells us how to count labelled copies if
you have these epsilon regularity
conditions which is exactly what this
case so so count is good
another easy implication
yes can implies c4 or this is actually
just tautological c4 condition is a
special case of of the count hypothesis
all right so let's move on to some
additional implications that require a
bit more work so what about c4 implies
Co degree so this is where we need to do
this kind of Cauchy Schwarz exercise so
let's start with c4 so assume the c-4
condition and suppose you have this
okay so let's so I want to deduce that
the co degree condition is true but
first let's think about just what is the
sum of these Co degrees as I vary U and
V over all pairs of vertices
so this is the a picture so that is
equal to the sums of degrees squared
which now by cauchy-schwarz you can
reduce to be at least n times 2 raised
to the number of edges namely the sum of
the degrees
I think squared so now we assumed the
c-4 condition actually we assume that G
has the density yes written up there so
this quantity is P squared plus Pluto 1
times n which is what you should expect
in a random graph of GMP okay so that's
but that's not quite what we're looking
for okay so this is just the sum of the
co degrees what we actually want is the
deviation of co degrees from its
expectation so to speak you know here's
a important technique from probabilistic
component works is that if you want to
control the deviation of a random
variable one thing should look at is the
variance so if you can control the
variance then you can control the
deviation and this is a method known as
the second moment method and that's what
we're going to do here so what we'll try
to show is that the second moment of
this code agrees a meter
sum of their squares it's also what you
should expect as if the random setting
and then you can put them together to
show what you want so this quantity here
well what is this we just saw see up
there it's also called degree square
squared so this quantity is also the
number of labeled copies of c4
not quite because you might have two
vertices and the amber at the same
vertex so I incorporate a small error so
it's really a sub it's a cubic error but
certainly sub n to the fourth and we
assume that the number of labeled copies
of c-4 by the support condition is no
more than basically P to the 4 times and
raise to the power 4 okay so now you
have a first moment for some average and
you have some control in the second
moment I can put them together to bound
the deviation using this idea of
controlling variance code degree
deviation is upper bounded by okay so
here using Cauchy Schwartz it's upper
bounded by basically the same sum except
I want to square the summoned this also
gets rid of the pesky absolute value
sign which is not nicely algebraically
behaved now at the square and I can
expand the square
okay so I expand the square into these
terms and the final term here it's P 2 4
& 6 all right but I have controlled
individual terms from the calculations
above so I can upper bound this
expression by what I'm writing down now
and basically you should expect that
everything should cancel out because
they do cancel all in a random case but
of course it's a sin if you check it's
it's important to write down this
calculation so if everything works all
right everything should cancel out and
indeed it you cancel out and you get
this so everything should cancel out and
you get a little o of n cubed I have to
summarize in this implication from c42
to Co degree what we're doing is were
controlling the variance of Co degrees
using the c4 condition and a second
moment bound showing that the c-4
condition you know trumps over to a col
degree condition
any questions so far okay so I'll let
you ponder in this calculation the next
one that will do is Co degree implies
disk okay and that will be a calculation
in a very similar flavor but it will be
a slightly longer by a similar flavor
calculation so let me do that after the
break alright so what we've done so far
so let's summarize the chain of
implications that we have already proved
so first we started with showing that
the two versions of disk are equivalent
and then we also noticed that disk
implies count through the counting lemma
so we also observe that count implies c4
tautologically and c-4 implies code
agree okay so the next natural thing to
do is to complete this circuit and show
that the code agree condition implies
that the discrepancy condition so that's
what we do next and in some sense you
know these two steps you should think of
them as going in this natural chain
where C 4 so C 4 is 4 like this C 4 code
agree condition is really about that and
disk it's really about single edges as
you can go from top if you you have you
you get much more power so it's going in
the right direction going downstream so
to speak so that's what we're doing now
going downstream and then you go
upstream via the counting number all
right
let's do code degree implies disk so we
want to show the discrepancy condition
which is one written up there but before
that let me first show you that the
degrees do not vary too much so that the
degrees are fairly well distributed
which is what you should expect in a
pseudo random graph right so you don't
expect a half the vertices half into
Greece twice the other half so that's
the first thing I want to establish if
you look at degrees this variant this
this deviation is it's not too big okay
so like before we've seen absolute value
sign we see some so what do you coffee
shorts coffee Schwartz allows us to
bound this quantity replacing the
summoned by a sum of squared
a square so I can expand the square so
let me expand the square I get that
so just expanding this square inside and
you see this degree squared is that
picture so that's some of code degrees
and some of the degrees is just a number
of edges
okay but we now assume the code agree
condition which in particular implies
that the sum the code agrees is roughly
what you expect so the sum of the code
agrees should be P Square and cubed plus
a little ol and cube error at the end
likewise the number of edges is by
assumption what you would expect in a
random graph and then a final term and
like before of course it's good to do it
since then if you check everything
should cancel out so what you end up
with is little o of N squared showing
that the degrees do not vary too much
and once you have that promise then we
move on to the actual discrepancy
condition so this discrepancy is can be
rewritten as the sum over vertices
little X in big x degree from little X
to Y minus key times the size of y okay
so rewriting this sum of course what
should we do next
Cosi sorts great so what do you call
shorts okay so here's a here's a
important step or a trick if you will so
what do you coach is shorts and
something very nice happens we need your
coffee shorts here instead okay so you
can write down the expression that you
obtain when you do coffee shorts so we
do that first
okay so here's a step which is very easy
to cross over but I want to pause and
emphasize this step because this is
actually really important what I'm going
to do now is to observe that the summon
is always non-negative therefore I can
enlarge the sum from just little X in X
to the entire vertex set and this is
important right so this is important
that we had to do coffee shorts first to
get a non negative someone you couldn't
do this in the beginning so you do that
and okay so I have this sum of squares
so I expand expand I write out all these
expressions
and now the little x-range over the
entire vertex set all right so what was
the point of all of that so you see this
expression here the degree of from
little X to big Y squared okay so what
is that how can we rewrite this
expression
honey little X Y squared
yeah so some of code degree of two
vertices in Y so Y Y prime in Y code
degree of little Y little Y Prime and
likewise the next expression can be
written as the sum of the degrees of
vertices in Y and the third term I leave
unchanged so now we've gotten rid of
these funny expressions we're just
degree from the vertex to a set and we
could do this because of this relaxation
up here so that was that was the point
we had to use this relaxation so now we
get these Co degree terms but now
because you have the Co degree terms and
we assume the Co degree hypothesis we
obtained that the sum is roughly what
you expect as a random case because all
the individual deviations do not add up
to more than little and cubed
that could agree some so what you expect
and the next term is some of the grease
it's also by what we did up there what
you expect and finally third term and as
earlier if you did everything correctly
everything should cancel and they do and
so what you get at the end is total of n
square
okay this completes this 4-cycle any
questions so far
okay so we're missing one more condition
and that's the eigenvalue condition so
so far everything had to deal with
counting various things all right so
what does eigenvalue have to do with
anything
so the eigenvalue condition is actually
a particularly important one and we'll
see more of this in the next lecture but
let me first show you the equivalent
implications so what we'll show is that
the eigen gallery condition is the
equivalent to the c-4 condition so
that's that's the goal I'll show you
covalent between I and c4
so first implies the c-4 condition
because up to so instead of counting
cforce which is a little bit actually
not it's been annoying to do actual
cforce just like earlier we want to
consider homomorphic copies which are
also labeled walks so closed walks of
length 4 so up to a cubic error the
number of labeled C force is given by
the number of closed walks of length 4
which is equal to the trace of the
fourth power of the adjacency matrix of
this graph
okay and the next thing is super
important so the next thing is this is
sometimes called the trace method that
one important way that the eigenvalues
of the spectrum of a graph or matrix
relates to other combinatorial
quantities is via this trace so we know
that the trace of the fourth power is
equal to the fourth moment of the
eigenvalues okay so if you haven't seen
a proof of this before I encourage you
to go home and think about it so this is
this is an important identity of course
4 can be replaced by any number up here
and well now you have the eigenvalue
condition so i can estimate this sum
there's a principal term namely lambda 1
right so that's the big term everything
else is small and the smallness is
supposed to capture pseudo randomness
but the big term you have to analyze
separately so the big term okay so let
me write it out so the big term you know
that it is P to the 4n to the 4 plus
total of 4 ok so the next thing is what
to do with the middle terms so we want
to show that the contribution in total
is not too big so what can we do well so
let me first try something
so first well see that each one of these
guys is not too big so maybe let's pound
each one of them by go to all of em so
raise to 4 but then there n of them so
you have to multiply by an extra n and
that's too much that's not good enough
so we cannot individually pound each one
of them and this is a this is a novice
mistake so this is something that will
actually we'll see this type of
calculation later on in the term when we
discussed Roth theorem but you're not
supposed to bound these terms individual
the better way to do this or the correct
way to do this is to pull out just a
couple you know some but not all of
these factors so it is upper bounded by
you take max off in this case you can
take out with one or two but you take
out let's say in two factors and then
you leave the remaining sum intact in
fact I can leave I can even put lambda
one back into the remaining so so so
that is true so what I've written down
is just true as inequality and now I
apply the hypothesis on the sizes of the
other lambdas so one I pulled out is
little Olaf N squared and now what's the
second sum that sum is the trace of a
squared which is just the twice the
number of edges of the graph so that's
also at most N squared so combining
everything you have the desired bound on
the C for count of course this gives you
an upper bound but we also did a
calculation before the break that shows
you that the C for bound is a lower
bound as well so really having the
correct
I can value this already already shows
you that the C for bound is correct in
both directions but because we this is
the main term and then everything else
is small okay the final implication is C
for implies eigen value
okay for this one I need to explore this
following important property of the top
eigenvalue so this is something that we
also saw last time which is the
interpretation of the top eigen value of
a matrix interpreted as so this is
sometimes called the Kuran Fisher
criterion or there actually this is a
special case of Kuran Fisher okay this
is a basic linear algebra fact if you
are not familiar with it I recommend
looking it up that the top eigen value
of a matrix of a real symmetric matrix
is characterized by the maximum value of
this quadratic form let's say if X is a
non zero vector so in particular if I
set X to be a specific vector I can
lower bound lambda 1 so if we set this
boldface one to be the oh one vector in
R raised to the number of vertices of G
then the lambda one of the graph is at
least this quantity over here the
numerator and denominators are all easy
things to evaluate the numerator is just
twice the number of edges because you
are summing up all the entries of the
matrix and the new denominator is just n
so the top eigenvalue is at least
roughly PM
okay so what about the other eigenvalues
or the other eigenvalues I can again
refer back to this moment formula
relating a trace and closed walks it is
at most the trace of the fourth power
minus the top eigenvalue raised to the
fourth power some of the other
eigenvalue raised to the fourth power
and for here we're using the force an
even number okay so you have this over
here so having a c4 hypothesis and also
knowing what lambda one is allows you to
control the other lambdas
she lambda one cannot be greater than
much greater than PN also comes out at
the same calculation yep thank you yeah
so there's a correction so lambda one is
so so in other words the little always
always respect you the constant density
okay yep okay so the question is in I
can value implies C for said something
about the lower bound so I'm not saying
that so as written over here what this
is what we have proved I saw him but
when you think about the pseudo
randomness condition for C for it
shouldn't be just that the number C for
count is and most something should be
that in close to that which would be
implied by the c4 condition itself
because we know always it is the case
that the c-4 count is at least compare
what it is compared to the random case
one more thing I said was that lambda
one you also know that it is at most P
and plus n right because
so this finishes the proof of the Chong
Graham Wilson theorem on quasi random
graphs and we stated all of these
hypotheses and they're all equivalent to
each other and I want to emphasize again
the most surprising one is that c4
implies everything else they're fairly
weak seeming condition seemingly weak
condition this just having the correct
number of copies of labeled C force is
enough to guarantee all of these other
much more complicated looking conditions
and in particular just having the C for
count correct implies that the counts of
every other graph H is correct now one
thing I want to stress is that the Chun
Graham Wilson theorem it's really about
dense graphs and by dense here I mean P
constant of course the theorem as stated
is true if you let P equals to zero so
there I said P strictly between 0 and 1
but it's also ok if you let P equal to 0
you don't get such interesting theorems
but but it is still true but for sparse
graphs what you really want to care
about is approximations at the correct
order of magnitude so what I mean is
that you can write down some sparse
analogues for P going to 0 so P as a
function of n going to 0 as n goes to
infinity ok so let me just write down a
couple of examples but I won't do all of
them and you can imagine what they
should look like so disk should say this
quantity over here the discrepancy
condition is
not all of P M squared because P N
squared is the edge density overall so
that's the quantity you should compare
against and not N squared if you're
compare N squared you know you're
cheating because N squared is much
bigger than the actual edge density
likewise the number of labeled copies of
age yes I want to put the little ol 1
plus little in front right so instead of
plus little ol end to the H at the end
as you understand the difference there
so for sparse this is the correct
normalization that you should have when
P is allowed to go to 0 as a function of
N and you can write down all of these
conditions right I'm not saying there's
a theorem you can write down all these
conditions and you can ask is there also
some notion of equivalence I'm sorry are
these corresponding conditions also
equivalent to each other and the answer
is emphatically no absolutely not so all
of these equivalent tests fail for
sparse some of them are still true in
some of the easier ones that we did for
example the two versions of discs are
equivalent that's the okay and some of
these calculations involving
cauchy-schwarz or you know mostly still
ok but the one that really fails is the
counting lemma
and let me explain why with an example
so I want to give you an example of a
graph which looks pseudo random in the
sense of disk but has no C for let's say
C 3 count also has no C for Campbell
just Xu has no triangle as the Keene
correct number of triangles alright so
what's this example so let P be some
number which is no off 1 over root n so
some decaying quantity with N and let's
consider GMP well how many triangles do
we expect in GMP so let's think of
Pierre just slightly below 1 over root n
so the number of triangles in GMP in
expectation so that's that's the
expected number and you should expect
the actual number to be roughly around
that but on the other hand the number of
edges it's also expected to be okay so
this quantity here and you expect that
the actual number of edges to be very
close to it but P is chosen so that the
number of triangles is significantly
smaller than the number of edges so
asymptotically smaller fewer copies of
triangles than edges so what we can do
now is remove
an edge from each copy of a triangle in
this GNP we removed a tiny fraction of
edges because the number of triangles is
much less than number of edges we remove
the tiny fraction of edges and as a
result we do not change the discrepancy
condition up to a small there error so
the discrepancy condition still holds
however the graph has normal triangles
so you have this pseudo random graph in
one sense namely of having discrepancy
but fails to be pseudo random in a
different sense namely has no triangles
yep we're question to the condition c4
and coda we still hold here basically
downstream is okay but upstream is not
okay so you can go from Seaforth code
agree to disk but you can't go upward
and understanding how to rectify the
situation may perhaps adding additional
hypotheses to make this true so that you
could have counting llamas for triangles
and other graphs in sparser graphs
that's an important topic and this is
something that we'll discuss at greater
length in non-black not next lecture but
the one after that and this is in fact
related to the green-tailed theorem
which allows you to prove similarities
term among the primes the primes contain
arbitrarily long arithmetic progressions
because the primes are also a sparse set
so as density going to zero density that
came like 1 over log and according to
prime number theorem but you want to do
regularity method so you have to face
this kind of issues so just okay so
we'll discuss that more length in a
couple of lectures but for now just a
warning that everything here it's really
about dense graphs the next thing I want
to discuss is an elaboration of what
happens to these eigenvalue conditions
[Applause]
so for dense graphs in some sense
everything is very clear from this
theorem like once you have this theorem
they're all equivalent you can go back
and forth and you know you lose a little
bit like epsilon here and there but
everything is more or less the same but
if you go to sparser world then you
really need to be much more careful we
need to think about other tools and so
the remainder of today I want to just
discuss one pretty simple but powerful
tool relating I can values on one hand
and a discrepancy condition on the other
hand right so you can go from eigenvalue
to discrepancy by going down this chain
but it's actually there's a much quicker
route and this is known as the expander
mixing them for simplicity and really
will make our life much simpler we're
only going to consider T regular graphs
here T regular means every vertex s
degree T same word but different meaning
from epsilon regular and unfortunately
that's just the way this so T regular
and we're going to have n vertices and
the adjacency matrix has eigenvalues
lambda 1 lambda 2 and so on arranged in
decreasing order let me write lambda as
the maximum in absolute value of the
eigenvalues except for the top one in
particular this is either the absolute
value of the second one or the last one
as I mentioned earlier at the top
eigenvalue is necessarily deep because
you have all ones vector as an
eigenvector so the expander mixing lemma
says that if I look at to vertex subsets
the number of edges between them
compared to what you would expect in a
random case so just like in a disk
setting but here the correct density I
should put is d over N this quantity is
upper bounded by lambda times the root
of the product of x and y so in
particular if this lambda so everything
except the top eigenvalue is small then
this discrepancy should be small and you
can verify with what we did that it's
consistent what we put what we just did
all right
so let's prove the expander mixing lemma
which is pretty simple given what we've
discussed so far
relating so there was this spectral
characterization up there of the top I
can value so we can let J be B or once
matrix let J be the old ones matrix and
we know that the all one's vector is an
eigenvector of the adjacency matrix of G
with eigen value D so the eigen
decomposition of J is also the ovince
vector and it's complement so we now see
that a sub G minus T over and J has the
same
I can vectors as AG so you can choose
the eigenvectors for that it's the same
set of eigenvectors of course we
consider this quantity here because this
is exactly the quality that comes up in
this expression once we hit it by
characteristic vectors of subsets from
left and right okay so so what are the
eigenvalues okay so the eigenvalues so a
previously had eigenvalues blend the 1
through lambda and but now the top one
gets chopped down to 0 so you can check
this explicitly so you can check this
explicitly by checking that if you take
this matrix multiplied by the or ones
vector you get 0 and if you have an
eigenvector eigenvalue pair then hitting
this by any of the other ones gets you
the same as in a because now the
condition or the other eigen vectors are
orthogonal to the or once vector all
right so now we apply the quran fisher
criteria which tells us that the number
in this discrepancy quantity
which we can write in terms of this
matrix it is upper bounded by the
product of the lengths of these two
vectors x and y multiplied by the
spectral norm not quite using the
version up there but I'm using the
spectral norm version which we discussed
last time it's essentially one up there
but you allow not just single x / x and
y and that corresponds to the largest
eigen value in absolute value which we
see that at most lambda so it's the most
lambda times size of x size of y okay
nothing is the proof of the expander
mixing lemma so the moral here is that
just like what we saw earlier when the
in the tense cadiz but for any
parameters so here there's no it's a
very clean statement you can even have
found the degree graphs he could be
constant if lambda is small compared to
D then you have this discrepancy
condition and the reason why this is
called an expander mixing lemma is that
there's this notion of expanders which
is not quite the same but very
intimately related to pseudo-random
grass so one property of pseudo-random
graphs that is quite useful in
particular in computer science is that
if you take a small subset of vertices
it has lots of neighbors so the graph is
now somehow in a cluster into a few
local pieces so there's lots of
expansion
and and and that's something that you
can guarantee using in the expand your
mixing lemma that you have lots of you
take a small set of vertices you can
expand outward so graphs with that
specific property taking small subset of
vertices always gets you loss of
neighbors are called expand their graphs
and these graphs play important role in
in particular in computer science in
designing algorithms improving
complexity results and so on but also
play important roles in graph theory and
combinatorics well next time we'll
address a few questions which are along
the lines of one how small can lambda B
as a function of T right so here it's as
if lambda is small compared to D then
you have this discrepancy but can it be
you know if D is let's say am Union how
small can lambda be that's one question
another question is is considering you
know everything that we've said so far
what can we say about let's say that the
relationship between some of these
conditions for sparse graphs but that
are somewhat special for example KD
graphs or vertex-transitive graphs and
turns out some of these relations are
also equivalent to each other